leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video warum
das video jetzt heute schon am freitag
kommt nicht am samstag ist für die die
gerne meine videos gucken vielleicht
wichtig deswegen wird in empfehlen
dranzubleiben und ja also ich weiß gar
nicht so recht was hier und jetzt
erzählen soll und wo ich anfangen soll
also ich kann euch auch nur eins sagen
ihr kennt das bestimmt manchmal im leben
wenn er euch sagt jetzt ist alles
scheiße ich habe keinen bock auf gar
nichts ich möchte zu hause und mache
nicht so viel und so ist das gerade
ungefähr bei mir ich denke ihr könnt
euch dann vorstellen falls sie schon mal
in so einer situation hat wie es euch
geht oder wie es mir jetzt gerade geht
und ich will euch auch den grund kann
ich nenne das geht auch ehrlich gesagt
gar nichts an aber es ist halt so ich
wollte euch das sagen und deswegen wird
auch morgen am samstag ein haupt video
geben also ich wollte es videos nur
machen damit ihr haltet euch nicht
wundert und damit ihr halt bist warum
kein video kommt das habe ich jetzt
erstmal so für mich entschieden ich bin
jetzt eine woche nicht zu hause und ich
brauche einfach mal abstand von diesem
ganzen youtube zeugs da ist jetzt halt
einfach mal so das braucht man halt als
youtuber auch mal und grad habe ich halt
dieser phase ich denke oder ich hoffe
ihr könnt dass alle verstehen
und ja ich bedanke mich natürlich oder
ich finde es so krass
ich habe schon auf instagram so viele
kommentare auf twitter so viele
kommentare die mich halt schon
aufmachern egal was jetzt gerade los ist
und gerade jetzt wird mir auch ziemlich
deutlich dass ich richtig froh bin jetzt
über 50.000 menschen zu haben die hinter
mir stehen ich hoffe ihr werdet weiter
hinter mir stehen dass ihr mir richtig
wichtig und danke dass ihr alle so
zahlreich meine videos schaut
ich hoffe das werde ich auch in zukunft
weiterhin tun und wir sehen uns dann
wahrscheinlich schon bald wieder also
wird nicht lange dauern zehn tage 14
tage ich muss mir das ganze mal durch
den kopf gehen lassen ansonsten ich hab
gesagt 2015 wird man ja wird auch mein
jahr
ich gebe mir mühe und auch mein gutes
jahr und bis bald
meine leute